foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing the future of the Harry
Potter franchise specifically what
direction Warner Bros will take if they
decide to further pursue a potential
Harry Potter show I'm also going to be
discussing the future of Fantastic
Beasts over the last couple of years
we've been teased several times about
the potential for a Harry Potter reboot
whether in the form of a TV show or
movie most recently was three weeks ago
when Warner Bros CEO David zaslav
emphasized the importance and
significance of the Harry Potter IP
belonging to them we're going to focus
on franchises he said what are the
movies that have brands that are
understood and loved everywhere in the
world we haven't done Harry Potter in 15
years the DC movies and the Harry Potter
movies provided a lot of the profits for
Warner Bros over the past 25 years he
added if we can do something with JK on
Harry Potter sir going forward and it
wasn't long before zaslav statement that
Warner media's former CEO Jason collar
also discussed Harry Potter's potential
as well as his intentions for creating a
Harry Potter TV show there's this little
thing called Harry Potter which is one
of the most beloved franchises and we're
incredibly thankful to be able to
partner with JK Rowling and so I would
argue there's a lot of fun and potential
there as well killar told the Morgan
Stanley technology media and
Telecommunications Conference during a
session that was webcast but the CEOs
with more power and potential than
anyone to reintroduce The Wizarding
World also always seem to leave out the
little details what form of the reboot
of Harry Potter take and what area of
the Wizarding World would it hone in on
with obscure statements being released
from back to back CEOs I can't help but
Wonder are they just pulling at our
heartstrings or is this an act actual
possibility first I want to discuss why
I think that a Harry Potter reboot may
actually be a relatively imminent
possibility and then I want to dive into
my predictions for what this show movie
might have in store but before we get to
that I want to discuss the elephant in
the room Fantastic Beasts and what this
film franchise's failure could mean for
the future of Harry Potter we're now
seven months to post secrets of
Dumbledore the third installment of the
Fantastic Beasts series and things are
not looking good where once there was
genuine hope for a five-part film series
looking at the adventures of newt's
Commander as well as some of the
Wizarding world's Origins now it's
looking an awful lot like they decided
to end it at three Fantastic Beasts 3
was comparatively a box office flop and
Warner Bros recently announced that
there are currently no plans to continue
the franchise with a fourth film but
much like the Phoenix the death of
Fantastic Beasts may present the
opportunity for another Harry Potter
spin-off to Rise From the Ashes
personally I enjoyed Fantastic Beasts
and I did genuinely feel that they were
heading in the right direction however I
would venture to say that is an unpop
popular opinion and while Warner CEOs in
the past have openly made remarks about
alternative Harry Potter spin-offs the
reality is their attention focus and
funding was all being poured into
Fantastic Beasts until now now that no
Harry Potter films are in production or
even pre-production Warner Bros have all
the time and resources in the world to
reintroduce the Harry Potter story from
a more fan-friendly angle Warner Bros if
you're listening this is what I think
you should make first of all An Origin
story for the Marauders the Marauders
were a group of mischievous young boys
who attended Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and was a dream during the
1970s these four boys were characters
that you've probably heard of James
Potter Sirius Black Remus Lupine and
Peter Pettigrew the quartet of boys
began their studies in 1971. the same
year as Severus Snape and they all had
one thing in common they were all
gryffindors before the Sorting ceremony
even happened the boys hit it off and
when they were eventually sorted into
the same house they knew that they were
destined to be friends though the boys
got home with many of their other
classmates this particular group of four
boys had a truly special bond and they
eventually came up with a name for their
group they were the Marauders the boys
had a lot in common beyond the fact that
all of them were gryffindors as they all
also happen to be huge troublemakers if
there was a rule at Hogwarts they were
hell-bent on breaking it and they were
truly notorious for their rule breaking
and mischief-making their group existed
for the duration of the time they spent
at Hogwarts from 1971 to 1978 and after
graduating they even all went on to join
the Order of the Phoenix a secret
society founded by Dumbledore that
opposed Lord Voldemort this is a group
of four characters that are integral to
the Harry Potter story that already have
a pre-established backstory that could
easily be adapted into an independent
narrative James is the father of the boy
who lived series Black is the man who
lost his friends and basically his
entire life in one fateful night Lupine
is the boy who was bitten by the
notorious fenrir greyback and Pettigrew
is the sniveling excuse for a man that
went down a very dark path these are
four massive characters and I think that
I can certainly speak for other fans as
well when I say that this could be a
massive opportunity to expand the Harry
Potter World the next spin-off that I
want to see made involves none other
than Lord Voldemort Voldemort has always
intrigued me and when we got to see
glimpses into his past and varying
stages of his life I was left even more
intrigued we know that Voldemort turns
into a murderous dark wizard intent on
dominating The Wizarding World and
achieving blood Purity but what I want
to see at the steps in his childhood
that got him to that point I want to see
him in world's orphanage and witness how
he interacted with the other children I
also want to see him at Hogwarts making
friends with the original Death Eaters I
want to see him grow up a Voldemort's
origin story could be a great way of
going back into Wizarding history and
doing a character analysis on the
primary antagonist of the Harry Potter
films the next spin-off that I'd like to
C involves the four Hogwarts Founders
and the founding of the school itself
Hogwarts goes with Harry Potter like
Marmite goes with toast they're meant to
be so in my eyes it only makes sense to
provide an origin story that explains
how the school came to be the founders
are such enigmatic figures powerful
Wizards thought to be more powerful than
modern day Wizards and I want to see
that on the big screen or at the very
least the small screen in my house
Hogwarts was founded at some point
during the 10th century when two witches
and two wizards got together and decided
that they had an assaulting Hat's own
words the self-same yearning to make the
world's best magic school these Founders
were godric Gryffindor Rowena Ravenclaw
Salazar Southern and Helga Hufflepuff
the original Craters of the four
Hogwarts houses the school itself was
built hidden off somewhere in the
Scottish Highlands the exact location is
never actually revealed and this was
because the 10 century was a time of
hardship for witches and wizards during
this time every day witches and wizards
were being persecuted by Muggles who
were intensely hostile when it came to
witnessing sources of magic this was a
different time a time very much unlike
what we are used to seeing in the
magical world wouldn't you like to know
about the struggles wizard kind faced in
the 10th Century what the OG Hogwarts
Founders were like this is a show I'd
really like to see made but for now you
could probably pass some of the time by
watching my complete history of Hogwarts
and the founders next up we've got the
origins of none other than Albus
Dumbledore Albus was a magical Prodigy
he was able to do things with the wand
that no one had seen before and given
that we're only really shown the old age
Dumbledore I really want to see what he
was like as a boy the original direction
of Fantastic Beasts was centered around
his defeat of Gaelic Grindelwald who
plays quite a large role in Dumbledore's
story
but what I want to say is Dumbledore's
father being sent to Azkaban and
Dumbledore's sister being killed after
being caught in the crossfire of a
three-way duel involving aberforth Albus
and Grindelwald I want to see all of
this on screen and the subject matter is
certainly there the next direction that
Warner could take which may be a little
bit riskier would be to explore one of
the other Wizarding schools we know from
the Harry Potter films there are
alternative academic institutions such
as bobato the French magical school and
durmstrang the northern European magical
school but did you know that they're
actually 11 Wizarding schools in total
aside from the ones already mentioned
this number includes schools like
Castello bruschu a Brazilian Wizarding
school that's located amid the Amazon
rainforest called of Stories the
Wizarding School of Russia located on a
hidden section of Lake ladoga ilvermorny
North America's Wizarding School located
at the highest peak of Mount Greylock
mahutukoro Japan School of magic located
on the topmost point of the volcanic
island of Minami Iwo Jima and wogadu
Africa's Wizarding School located in the
mountains of the Moon the renzori
mountains of Uganda found at the source
of the Nile River with so many Wizarding
schools around the globe it would be a
complete waste to not try and explore
them further but for now if you want to
learn a bit more about the schools I've
mentioned check out the video on screen
next up we've got the goblin rebellions
despite the state of goblin Wizarding
relations being less than favorable in
our current ERA there were many periods
in history where things were actually a
lot worse in fact between 1612 and 1890
there were three documented rebellions
from goblins who were sick of their
status in Wizarding Society the first
goblin Rebellion took place in 1612 near
hogsmeade Village the goblin forces took
an inn as their base and ravaged the
nearby buildings setting many of them on
fire the exact number of lives laid down
on both sides has been lost to the years
but the casualties were remarkably high
at least according to Hogwarts fifth
year History of Magic class and when we
look at the exact chords of this
Rebellion there's no shortage of reasons
for why the Goblins would have started
it goblins were responsible for far more
skilled tasks goblins forged the most
powerful weapons indestructible armor
and through their natural propensity for
hoarding gold goblins basically kept the
entire Wizarding economy moving forward
and yet Wizards and witches looked down
on them wherever they went the next
Goblin rebellion was in 1752 and this
one was even bloodier than the battle at
hogsmeade over a hundred years prior
this time the Goblins pledged themselves
to an unlikely Alliance apart ship with
werewolves with the Primal beasts on
their side the Goblins wreaked havoc
across Britain it wasn't until Minister
for magic who feised his Gore was
elected that the rebellion was stomped
for good but conflict with the goblins
didn't stop there with yet another
Rebellion kicking off in 1890 with a
goblin named ranrock ultimately by the
time of Harry Potter's enrollment at
Hogwarts the goblin rebellions were
relegated to a short series of lectures
in the history of magic courses but I
think there's more than enough meat here
to turn these rebellions and the tension
between wizard kind and Goblin Kind into
a TV show or movie my last suggestion
for a potential spin-off centers around
the ministry for magic specifically the
aura office auras are magical law
enforcement officials that work for the
Department of magical law enforcement
inside the ministry of magic their job
is simple capture dark Wizards and other
criminals in an effort to keep the
Wizarding public safe this last
suggestion poses a unique opportunity in
that it could take place in the present
day and would allow Warner to cast some
of the original Harry Potter actors
including Daniel Radcliffe Emma Watson
and Rupert Grint after graduation from
Hogwarts Ron and Harry did actually end
up working in the ore office for a
number of years so this could be perfect
obviously with such an in-depth universe
and so many different characters
timelines there are tons of
possibilities but I think I've managed
to narrow down the biggest ones what do
you think do you agree with any of the
ideas I've proposed what shows would you
like to see made leave a comment down
below and as always if you enjoy the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget and to live